[Music]
jonathan is with us in college station
texas aggieland
hey jonathan welcome to dave ramsey show
hey dave how you doing good man what's
up i heard about you when i was growing
up but i recently
looked into you and my wife and i are
about 130 000 in debt and another 178 on
our mortgage
um i'm ready to start getting debt free
but my wife looks at it
like uh god put us here and he could
take us away tomorrow so what's the
point of trying to get debt free
um well that's true yeah
yeah horrible theology
that's like a farmer standing in the
middle of a dirt field going
god put us here if he wants his corn to
be planted i guess he'll plant some corn
of course you've got to impact the
situation you know stand around and wait
on god to fix something he's going to
tell you you get your butt in gear and
he'll join you in the process
but farmers have to plant corn it
doesn't grow because god
because the farmer just prayed and said
god's going to put corn in the ground
then god sends the rain and god sends
the
the wind and god sends the nutrition and
the dirt
but you have to put the corn in the
ground you got to put the work in
standing around and say well god will
take care of it that's that's ridiculous
it's insulting
yeah i'm trying to get her on the same
um
you know rice and bean thing you guys
think you say yeah how old are you guys
uh 25. okay so what's your household
income
i made i just recently started my own
business um
started without any debt and i make uh
1500 a week
after taxes and what does she make
she's a stay-at-home mom we have four
kids at 25 years old
yeah we started young okay and um
yeah you did yeah and uh uh yeah
yeah yeah
so you're making 50 60 000 bucks a year
okay
and you got who got all these student
loans
i got 50 000 million student loans at i
couldn't work 100 full time well okay
you got 50 000. what you said there's
130 what's the other 80
um a couple vehicles uh
totaling 60 000. and then
uh ten thousand credit cards and about
ten thousand and personal loans
all right i'm gonna be a smart i like
you ready
god says for you to sell your cars i
agree you know i know that
it's in the bible the bible says the
blessings of the lord
have no sorrow added to them
these cars are not from god they are not
a blessing because they have sorrow
added to them
you're so freaking broke you can't
breathe you're 25 years old making 60
grand
and you owe 60 000 on two stupid butt
cars now that's my smart aleck okay
i got it over with now now you and i can
be friends and i'll help you okay
okay
all right so here's what we've got to do
you guys have to decide
as a couple that your
shortest distance to a real high quality
life
is to be clear of debt so that you can
build
wealth and be great moms and dads to
these babies and be able to pay for
their college so they don't end up with
student loan debt later okay
and both of you you and your wife
one of your highest desires i can tell
your family people
is to be a blessing to your children and
that is going to require
that you clean up the mess that the two
of you have made and it's going to
require some sacrifice
and no discipline seems pleasant at the
time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
the way i say that is
if you live like no one else later you
can live and give like no one else
but you guys have made a significant
mess by not paying attention
and the only way it's going to be
cleaned up is by paying attention
so if you were my son i have a son
that's 28
and i would sit down with him and my
daughter-in-law assuming she would
listen to me
um and my daughter-in-law would but your
wife might
not um would be guys sell your cars
let's get on beans and rice rice and
beans budget let's
really roll up our sleeves and clean up
this mess as fast as we possibly can
because dude if you had no payments but
a house payment as your business
continues to grow you're going to become
wealthy agreed
agreed yeah so i'll help you with that
now that i've been a smart elect to you
i'll give you
ramsey plus for a year if i give you the
ramsey plus membership which puts you
into financial peace university
can you convince her to put the kids to
bed tonight or tomorrow night
and start watching the videos with you
can you get her to watch one with you
i i she's usually open to uh like open
to
viewing something before making a final
decision i think i think
well it doesn't cost you anything so you
have to make a decision it's free
the only decision is just throw in the
trash or not but um
i'm giving it to you for free a several
thousand dollar gift here
because i've been 25 i've been scared
and i've been a young dad that didn't
know what the crap to do
and messing up left and right and so i
know exactly who you are
but here's the thing uh
scriptures are very very clear if you're
gonna quote god or if you're gonna say
you know god will take care of us then
you have if you're gonna if you're gonna
use god as your paradigm
which i believe i'm a believer then
you've got to use your scripture
as a thing and scripture is real
clear that we live in a cause and effect
universe you reap what you sow
what you put into the ground is what
comes out of the ground
what you put into your life is what
comes out of your life
scriptures are real clear like for
instance proverbs says
the diligent prosper
you know what diligence is working your
butt off
that's what diligence is prosper
and so there is nowhere in scripture
with a few rare exceptions of miracles
and that's why we call them miracles
because they're rare and they're an
exception
that the way god put his universe
together is that you just stand back and
he just shovels candy into your lap
it's not in there he loves us
and if we being evil know how to give
our kids good gifts how much more so our
father in heaven he allows us to enjoy
wonderful things but they are what in
ecclesiastes it causes the fruit of our
labor
meaning that we labored to get the fruit
and so work and working a plan
the mind of man plans his ways the lord
directs his steps
work and working a plan don't build a
tower without first counting the cost
jesus said
lest you get halfway up and you're
unable to finish and all who see you
begin to mock you and say
this man began to build and was unable
to finish having a plan
working a plan is all in scripture
standing at the edge of your field as a
farmer and saying grow corn
when you've planted none is nowhere in
the bible
and so you've got to align yourself with
truth in order to be able to get to your
goals
and so you you're not afraid of hard
work hard work is the answer to your
situation
you hold on jonathan kelly i'll pick up
we'll get you guys signed up for ramsey
plus and
hopefully she won't be too mad at me for
me picking on her so hard